our next speaker is michael kim uh
michael just completed his phd in the
stanford theory group
and he's not currently a uc berkeley
miller post doctor fellow
michael great um wait for the slide
great so we can go to the next slide um
thanks so these days predictive
algorithms are everywhere we look
they drive our cars and our economies
they're making medical predictions
and even sometimes telling us who we
should get married to
um and really algorithms are
increasingly used to make consequential
decisions about people and are having a
profound
impact on our daily lives and
while such predictive algorithms have
the potential to yield great benefits to
society
unfortunately for every amazing
algorithmic achievement you hear about
you also see like on the next slide
headlines
highlighting the bias and unfair
discrimination that can be baked into
these predictive algorithms
on the next side we discuss a specific
issue that came into focus recently in
the california elections
where prop 25 gave voters a choice to
eliminate
cash bail and replace it with a certain
risk assessment algorithm
now cash bail has long been understood
to discriminate against people on the
basis
of race and socioeconomics but critics
of the proposition
like the aclu of socal worried that the
risk assessment algorithm would exhibit
exactly the same issues of bias and
unfair discrimination
as cash bail itself and so it emits
lots of concern about bias and
prediction systems
it's actually quite easy to identify
examples where
the algorithms we're using are behaving
in a manner that somehow we feel is
unfair
but devising an effective strategy for
mitigating this algorithmic unfairness
is a bit more challenging
and that's where my research begins
we'll talk about it on the next slide
so rather than addressing each example
of bias as we see it on the fly
my research tries to take a more
foundational approach identifying
general patterns of unfair
algorithmic behavior and then
translating these patterns into formal
notions of fairness
in the language of theoretical computer
science and really a large focus of the
research
is on making sure that we have the right
definitions where we need to balance the
desire for general purpose solutions
as well as an awareness for the context
in which the notions will be applied
and ideally developing these definitions
will really help us to understand
what we can and cannot expect from
machine learned predictions
in a given context the eventual goal of
the research program is to develop
efficient machine learning that comes
with a provable guarantee of fairness
properties
much in the same way that modern
cryptography provides us in our browser
with a provable certificate
of security in our online transactions
on the next slide i want to give you a
flavor of the type of definitions that
we work with
so the main notion that we've been
studying for the past few years is
called multi-calibration
multi-calibration
says that predictions should appear
calibrated
not just overall but on every
sub-population that can be identified
within some computationally bounded
class of sub-populations
we show that the guarantees of
multi-calibration are significantly
stronger
than the corresponding guarantees of
group fairness
and we give algorithms that reduce the
problem of learning a multi-calibrated
predictor
to standard machine learning tasks
showing its feasibility
so finally on the last slide i want to
conclude
with a preview of some hot off the press
work where we start with a really simple
idea
and the idea is that perhaps fair
predictions
should somehow be indistinguishable from
a set of ideal predictions
now you have to be careful about exactly
how you make this intuition rigorous
but it leads us to a certain notion that
we called outcome to
indistinguishability
the framework outcome in
distinguishability for reasoning about
predictions
turns out to be very general even more
general than multi-calibration
and sets up a number of interesting
questions about learning and prediction
that we're excited to dig into further
thanks a lot